en todos los ejemplos que hemos
trabajado hasta ahorita nada más hemos
tenido un banco sin embargo en la
actualidad hay mucho más que un banco en
cada país vamos a ver qué sucede en esta
situación
para eso dibuje las hojas de balance de
tres bancos hipotéticos en un mundo
donde el oro sigue siendo el recurso de
reservas déjate las enseñaba para que
veamos qué sucede en este mundo mira
estas son dos aquí hay otra no cupieron
todas en una pantalla pero bueno vamos a
repasar un poquito este de qué se trata
la hoja de balance acá a la izquierda
tenemos el activo a la derecha tenemos
el pasivo hasta aquí verdad nada más
hasta aquí entonces déjalo marco de aquí
acá es pasivo y lo que resta es el
capital para ser consistente en cada
hoja de balance dibuje el capital en
color azul hito va pues el color azul
hito es el capital deja me pongo alguna
letra no se lo voy a poner por decir
algo entonces
todo eso es capital lo que está en
naranja es el edificio y lo que está en
amarillo en los activos es el oro que
realmente tenemos respaldado vale luego
cada una de las líneas en el lado
izquierdo dividen distintos tipos de
activos por ejemplo distintos presta
así en el lado derecho también tenemos
líneas divisoras que separan diferentes
cuentas de cheques pues de diferentes
personas ahora esta cosa que remarque en
verde en este banco de enmedio son las
notas bancarias que ha emitido recuerda
que hay dos formas en las cuales un
banco puede dar un pagaré podría
apoyarse a armarle una cuenta de cheques
a alguien con eso ya la gente puede
hacer cheques entre sí y la otra es
emitir pues estos papelitos que son
notas bancarias que pueden después
traerlas al banco e intercambiarlas por
una cantidad equivalente de oro pero
bueno en el banco del medio el área
verde son las notas bancarias arriba son
el área que está en morado y de modo
similar hasta acá abajo en color plata
no tenemos las notas bancarias del
tercer banco excelente ya logramos crear
un mundo en donde hay tres bancos ahora
cuál es el problema con todo esto o más
bien habrá algunos problemas pues bueno
hay algunos que yo veo así
inmediatamente
el primero es bueno que cada uno de
estos bancos podría tener diferentes
coeficientes de reserva en el vídeo
pasado hablé de ciertos requisitos de
reserva pero pensamos que ahorita
todavía no están que pues no sé cada
emprendedor
su banco por separado cada quien estudió
a sus clientes y se dio cuenta que podía
inventarse su coeficiente de reserva sin
problemas
entonces cada uno dijo pues estos son
mis clientes así se comportan y entonces
tengo que tener tanto en reservas
entonces a lo mejor el tercer banco el
de acá abajo puso un coeficiente de
reserva muy bajo porque vio que sus
clientes casi no sacaban y le puso 8%
eso quiere decir que por cada 100 piezas
de oro que tengan una cuenta de cheques
o en otras bancarias mantiene 8 piezas
de oro en reserva el de acá vamos a
poner que es 10 por ciento por decir
algo y el de arriba es muy cuidadoso y
guardo el 12 por ciento va entonces pues
no hay un coeficiente de reserva
consistente voy a escribirlo por aquí
arriba coeficiente de reserva de reserva
inconsistente entonces no igual no igual
va y bueno eso causa algunos otros
problemas mira supongamos que el de en
medio no mejor el de arriba el de arriba
fue el primer banco y fue muy cuidar
esto hizo que la gente confiara mucho en
él porque cuando depositaba su dinero y
lo quería de vuelta siempre podía
obtenerlo
el banco hacía muy buenas inversiones la
gente recibía sus intereses
todo en regla después con el paso del
tiempo esto del negocio de los bancos se
hizo bien atractivo y empezaron a salir
más entonces este bonito arriesgado que
quiso abrir su banco y no sé tal vez
algún día 9% de sus cuentas de cheques
quieren su dinero de regreso y éste no
va a poder pagarlo el de arriba el del
12% sabía que tenía que guardar 12 por
ciento porque el 9 por ciento podía
pasar entonces él pues fue cuidadoso
pero el de abajo nada más tenía un 8 por
ciento para que el resto estuviera
ganando intereses y un mal día no pudo
regresar el oro que le pidieron entonces
qué pasa todo el mundo empieza a hacer
retiros masivos de este banco pero no es
el único la gente empieza a perder la
confianza en el sistema bancario y hace
retiros masivos por todas partes la
verdad eso fue terrible porque número
uno porque estos dos de acá arriba si
habían sido bancos precavidos estos
bancos si podían pagar según sus
previsiones y número dos es que el banco
de abajo única
necesitaba un 1% más ese 1% en realidad
es bien poquito lo único que pasó es que
el banco no lo tenía a su disposición
sin embargo había otros bancos que sí lo
tenían y a lo mejor el banco podía pedir
prestado entonces a lo mejor a ese banco
si le conviene pedir prestado y claro a
los otros les conviene prestarle para
evitar esto de la crisis financiera
entonces el banco tendría solvencia a la
gente no le da miedo y así evitamos un
retiro masivo sistémico bueno ese es el
problema déjalo escribo por acá son
retiros masivos vamos a ponerlo por aquí
retiros masivos estos afectan a todo el
mundo en este mundo que nos inventamos
al parecer el sistema bancario es muy
frágil tan solo con que haya un eslabón
débil en la cadena puede caerse todo el
sistema un solo banco irresponsable
puede causar retiros masivos por todas
partes bueno pasemos al tercer problema
esta es una situación de la que ya
platicamos un poquito en vídeos pasados
pero en la actualidad ya no estamos tan
acostumbrados a vivirla en realidad es
un problema como de la época colonial y
consiste en que haya distintos tipos de
notas bancarias
eso es un problema por ejemplo el monito
de acá hace notas bancarias color morado
el segundo hace notas bancarias color
verde y el día está abajo hace notas
bancarias color plata no el tener
distintas notas número uno puede causar
confusión pero además pues hay problemas
de tipos de cambio a qué me refiero pues
por ejemplo el tercer monito que está
ocurriendo mucho riesgo quizás sus notas
bancarias no deberían de valer tanto
como las de los precavidos y esto es
difícil de medir
en fin se hacen muchos líos para los
banqueros va a ser terrible tener que
darle seguimiento a todos los tipos de
cambio andar pensando en que valen más
valen menos luego que les vamos a
cambiar el color porque un banco que hay
en bancarrota y entonces sus notas
bancarias ya no valen nada vaya hay
muchos problemas todos estos problemas
son causados por una moneda
inconsistente por una moneda
inconsistente en papel le voy a poner
así moneda
inconsistente
consistente creo que ya ves más o menos
a dónde va esto entonces cuál sería una
solución para todas estas cosas bueno
como le podríamos hacer para bueno el
número el problema uno no es tan grave
verdad para el problema uno podríamos
simplemente regular el coeficiente de
reservas pues a través de digamos una
ley entonces el gobierno podría decir
cuánto es el coeficiente o se podría
hacer una comisión para que decida no
tenemos que hacer toda una institución
para decidir eso con eso arreglamos el
problema 1 pero el problema 2 necesita
una solución un poco más fina como nos
inventamos un mecanismo para evitar los
problemas de retiros masivos de efectivo
si con este mecanismo además logramos
unificar la moneda entonces ya la
hicimos pues la clave está en la moneda
consistente cómo le hacemos pues sólo
podemos permitir que una institución
imprima moneda a esta institución le
vamos a llamar banco central
voy a dibujar su hoja de balance
entonces voy a copiar una de éstas
entonces supongamos que estos tres
bancos se reúnen y dicen sabes que vamos
a abrir una nueva institución donde
todos vamos a meter nuestras reservas de
oro entonces lo que sucede es que este
este y este banco dejan su oro aquí en
este banco central entonces déjame poner
el oro ahí en la hoja de balance no voy
a dibujar entonces ahí tenemos el oro
del banco de en medio arriba tenemos el
oro del banco de arriba todo eso se
queda ahí y luego lo que estos bancos
obtienen en vez de oro pues que es son
cuentas de cheques entonces son un
pasivo en el banco de reserva
voy a pintarlo aquí al ladito entonces
todo esto se convierte en cuentas de
cheques con el banco de reservas lo voy
a intentar dibujar aquí al ladito aunque
no tenga que ser así verdad éste va acá
este va para acá y este de aquí va para
arriba muy bien va déjame borrar la
parte de arriba de la hoja de balance
para no confundirnos entonces esto de
aquí sería la hoja de balance de el
banco de reserva va que pasa con esto
pues esto ya resuelve el problema de los
retiros masivos porque si en este mundo
verdad si el banco de hasta abajo
ahorita ya también tenemos regulación
verdad porque este banco central daría
las regulaciones pero bueno si por
alguna razón en el banco de hasta abajo
no sé el 11% de los clientes quieren su
dinero quieren su efectivo entonces el
banco aunque no tenga eso en reservas
ahora puede ir a su cuenta de cheques en
el banco central y pedir prestado para
pagarles a sus clientes la confianza se
mantiene y todos felices ahora vamos con
el asunto de las notas bancarias
supongamos que por ley estas notas
bancarias de los otros bancos ya se
cancelan y el único que puede emitir
notas bancarias es el banco central con
esto un banco puede no querer todo en su
cuenta de cheques del banco central si
no puede querer algo de lo que tiene en
efecto
digamos la mitad entonces no lo quiere
no lo quiere todo en cuentas de cheques
sino la mitad de esto la mitad de su oro
se convierte en otras bancarias del
banco de reserva vale entonces estas
notas bancarias del banco central son
las únicas que se pueden emitir con esto
ya resolvimos dos problemas número uno
lo de la moneda inconsistente y número
dos lo de los retiros masivos y mira
empieza a pasar un fenómeno muy extraño
ahorita como los bancos ya no tienen oro
en reservas entonces la gente empieza a
usar estas notas bancarias del banco
central como si fueran la moneda válida
en el país entonces toda la gente
empieza a usar esto para hacer sus
transacciones día a día y el oro pues el
oro se queda por acá el oro se queda
pues en las bóvedas en un lugar súper
seguro y súper secreto bueno con esto ya
resolvimos dos de los problemas que nos
falta
así coeficientes de reserva pero estos
están fáciles antes los iba a poner el
gobierno o una comisión pero ahora esta
institución que es el banco central
también puede establecer los ya nada más
nos falta platicar un poquito acerca de
los retiros masivos pero bueno es el
mecanismo del
ya habíamos platicado por ejemplo si en
este banco los clientes quieren pedir
mucho de su dinero así de modo que al
banco no le alcance entonces ahora el
banco simplemente puede ir a su cuenta
en el banco central y pedir prestado un
poco para poderle pagar a sus clientes
ahora si lo piensas un poquito con el
paso del tiempo la gente se va a
acostumbrar a esta nota única a esta
nota que es la nota bancaria del banco
central entonces pues van a empezar a
verlo como una muy buena unidad de
intercambio ya lo mejor cuando vayan al
banco ya no quieran oro sino prefieran
que el banco en vez de darles su oro así
en metal les dé muchos billetes y muchos
billetes de este banco de reserva
central en fin creo que ya dije muchas
veces la palabra reserva y la palabra
central en este vídeo espero que no haya
sido muy complicado en el siguiente
vídeo y creo que ya ves más o menos a
dónde va esto vamos a ver cómo estas
ideas nos van a permitir salir del
patrón oro y veremos otras cosas que
hace un banco central nos vemos